[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
facts 800-463-7297
pastor doug batchelor hello friends this
is pastor jean ross pastor doug is out
this evening but you are listening to
amazing facts bible answers live and how
about an amazing fact
your brain which weighs about three
pounds and makes up less than two
percent of your body's weight
uses
20 percent of your body's energy and
oxygen
and that's for good reason your brain
contains more than 400 miles of blood
vessels bringing nutrients to some 86
billion cells
the amount of sight sounds smells and
other bits of sensory information that
flood into your brain each millisecond
is dazzling an ordinary person has about
50 000 conscious thoughts each day
there's an average of a hundred thousand
chemical changes in your brain every
second no wonder your brain feels
exhausted at the end of a long day
and if you think you're in control of
all of your decisions well think again
about 95 percent of your decisions are
made at the subconscious level
often processed by vast amounts of
information stored in your memory files
then there is the second brain your
intestines which contain a hundred
thousand neuron processing 30 essential
neurotransmitters along with what's
called the happy molecule serotonin
that's probably why some decisions are
referred to as a get as a gut reaction
the ability of the human brain to store
information
is also astounding at the northwest
university in illinois research
psychologists estimated that the average
brain can store
2.5 million gigabytes of data
this means that all the information that
enters the brain is never erased the
problem is not storing the information
but recalling it at the right time
although the brain is amazingly complex
and powerful it is also very fragile
even the most brilliant minds can
experience disease memory loss
depression and dementia
in many cases the stored memories both
conscious and unconscious can cause
physical and emotional distress we might
wish that some of our memories could be
erased like a computer's hard drive but
these memories are hardwired in forever
what we need is a new software program
so to speak to help us filter past
experiences through new perspectives
well god offers just such a program in
the bible
energized by the holy spirit
and equipped with the truth of scripture
we can reinterpret everything that we
experience from a biblical perspective
leading to a healthier way of thinking
the saying is true unless we change our
minds nothing else changes
well friends we are glad that you have
tuned in for this edition of bible
answers live and if you have a bible
related question the number to call our
phone lines open is
800-463-7297 that is the phone line if
you have a bible related question
we'll be also giving you another number
800-835-6747 and that is our resource
phone line and we'll be handing out some
free material to help you in your study
of god's word
well we open the program talking about
the human brain
and we read the verse in romans chapter
12 verse 2 that says we are not to be
conformed to the world but be
transformed through our mind through
what we read what we think about
by filling our mind with spiritual truth
we have a free offer that we'd like to
make available to anyone who calls and
asks it is actually a book written by
pastor doug entitled who do you think
you are
and this is our free gift to anyone all
you have to do is just call and ask for
it the number to call is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book who do you
think you are and we'll be happy to send
that to anyone here in north america if
you're listening outside of north
america just visit the amazing facts
website just amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to read the book
there online and get more information
about how you can maybe get a digital
copy of the book who do you think you
are
well before we go to the phone lines we
recognize that the bible is god's book
and so we need the spirit to guide us as
we study so let's have a word of prayer
dear lord we are grateful for the
opportunity that we have to open up your
word and study together and father we
recognize that
it's your holy spirit that leads us into
a clear and full understanding of the
bible and so we ask the spirit to be
with us be with those who are listening
wherever they might be and lead us into
a clearer understanding of the bible for
we ask this in jesus name amen
well we're going to go to the phone
lines our first caller that we have is
calling jason from florida jason welcome
to the program
hello pastor ross hi how are you doing
well thank you
thanks for taking my call um
so my question for tonight is um
is it possible for someone
who
desires salvation but doesn't
necessarily
have a sincere genuine desire for god
himself
is it possible
for that person to actually be able to
seek
god with all of their hearts and the
reason why i'm asking this is because
um i'm not exactly right with god and
i've been asking for repentance for
months and months now but
i have yet to receive repentance and i
have
yet to find god and
um maybe it has to do because i'm just
not as earnest
or diligent as i should be because
this is a matter of life or death
but um
it just seems like i don't really desire
god it's really i just want to you know
not go to hell
and well you know i think i think that's
that's a starting point jason i mean
that's not the the ultimate reason why
we want to serve god is just so that we
can live forever and and we don't want
to be destroyed in the fires of hell but
that's definitely a starting point
because the bible is filled with
warnings so warning people to turn away
from their sinful
from this and relax from their sinful
attitudes
that is true you mentioned that god is
the one that gives us repentance and we
ought to ask for that we can say lord
please give me that deep
sincere repentance but in addition to
asking there are some practical things
that we can actually do
to
help god in bringing about that that
experience of genuine repentance for one
we want to start filling our mind with
spiritual truth
there might be some things in our life
that we are very much aware of that is
causing a hindrance
in our spiritual life
and we need to take the first step and
say lord i'm going to set this aside
maybe there's some things that have to
be thrown away
maybe we need to change some habits in
our life maybe even change some
relationships maybe we're hanging around
the wrong crowd
we need to make that first step
the bible speaks about bringing forth
fruits of repentance
so there is something that we can do
recognizing that it's god that works in
us to give us that sincere repentance
but we also have a work to do in laying
aside those things that we're aware of
and starting to
seek a spiritual
interaction so you know attend church
regularly get involved in bible study
get involved in prayer do everything you
can to grow spiritually
and then make those changes in your life
that the holy spirit might be convicting
you on
does that make sense jason
yes it absolutely does
thank you absolutely well i think that's
a good start and thank you for your
question it's an important question
uh next quarter that we have is uh rami
listening from florida rami welcome to
the program
yes hi uh thank you for taking my call
i
actually i have two questions the first
one is it lawful to
do exams
on saturday which that's the only time
the exam is scheduled
as well as going to the gym
the second question is
is it um
acceptable
to cut the relationship with a close
family member which is
causing
me
physical harm
to the point that i had to go to the
hospital it's not
physical abuse but it's emotional abuse
that is the two questions i have okay
well let's take him one at a time let's
start with with the second and then
we'll work our way to the first
so the second question asking is what do
we do in a family relationship where
somebody is um
abusing us maybe emotionally or uh
physically there are some of course
situations like that i think the first
thing we want to do is
do the best we can to try and restore
the relationship but a relationship is
two-way so you need to have
the person respond
if you're in a dangerous situation or
it's affecting your health there's
nothing wrong in in
putting some distance or some separation
between you and the one that is causing
that stress
uh hopefully it's just temporary and the
relationship can be restored
but you want to make sure that you know
physically and as far as health goes you
need to take care of yourself
but you also want to do everything you
can to try and restore and build that
relationship
are recognizing maybe pray for them
maybe that's all you can do depending
upon the situation but at least you can
pray try and be a positive example but
you don't always have to be around that
person that keeps adding additional
stress to your life
and that's where you need to pray for
guidance to help guide you in that
situation
um does does that make sense
remy
yes yes i i tried a lot but it seems
like
that door is totally closed so um to the
point i i
literally had to get admit to the
hospital
so
but you know becoming really dangerous
right no god doesn't want us to put
ourselves in a dangerous situation i
mean there are times where
the best you can do for a person in
relationship is pray for them and just
pray that the lord would speak to their
hearts and and soften their hearts so
that
you know they might be open down the
line and
live a good life be the best example of
a christian that you can well the second
part of the question you asked has to do
with um doing an exam on the sabbath day
sure the bible gives us the principle of
the sabbath uh you find it all the way
back in genesis genesis chapter two in
verse one talks about god creating the
earth in six days and then he rested on
the seventh day and therefore he blessed
the sabbath day and he set it apart so
the seventh day
the sabbath is set apart from all of the
other days of the week it is a memorial
of god's creative work it's an
opportunity for us to focus our
attention on him to lay us outside our
secular labors our own
pursuits they might not be bad not in
and of themselves but on the sabbath we
lay that aside we focus on god we gather
for corporate worship
so there are situations that come along
where somebody might have to take an
exam or maybe there is something they
have to do for work
the first thing you want to do is ask
for an exemption because it is your
sabbath and i know many times where i've
actually as a pastor written a letter
for one of the members of the church who
are asking
for some type of accommodation at work
because of their belief wanting to keep
the sabbath
and we do everything we can to assist
that and most times you'll find that
colleges or universities or works they
will try to accommodate you if you're a
good employee if you're a good student
they'll try and work with you
but what do you do if they refuse to
work with you and they refuse to
accommodate well i think it's one of
those things that we as christians need
to make a stand for it's like shadrach
meshach and abednego on the plane of
dura when the king commanded everyone to
bow down to the golden image
shadrach meshach and abednego had
already made up their minds that they
weren't going to violate one of the ten
commandments even if it meant going to
the fiery furnace and they stood firm
and they trusted in god and god
delivered them
so there are times where you know we do
everything we can
but at the end of the day we just turn
ourselves over to god and say lord i'm
going to stand for what i know to be
true please help
please intervene and we trust him
to work things out but we don't want to
compromise when it comes to
doing something that we know god does
not want us to do how can god bless us
if we are going to violate one of his
clear commandments
so in that case i would say no stand on
what you know to be right stand upon the
bible truth place it in god's hands
trust in him and let god work that out
does that mean
yes i'm glad i called okay well thank
you for calling i will do that thank you
thank you bye-bye
bye
we've got anthony listening in new york
anthony welcome to uh bible answers
live hello pastor how are you doing this
evening doing very well thank you
good good um my question is um
uh well i i at first i really didn't
have a bible verse to go with it but i
think amos chapter 3 verse 7
um
kind of suits the question i have and it
says
surely the lord god will do nothing but
he revealeth his secret
unto his servants the prophets and um i
know there's a lot of
craziness going on in the world today
and i know we you know look in matthew
chapter 24 and you know daniel in
revelation and we see the different
prophecies
that were foretold
of what's going to happen in the last
days
um but then a lot of times people look
at the things that the lord has revealed
to us through you know you know either
through you know the spirit of prophecy
or through you know his word um
as you know conspiracy theories
or or whatever and some you know
obviously you want to stay away from
conspiracy theories but we know that
there's an ultimate conspirator which is
satan so my question is where do we draw
the line between
conspiracy theory and
stand firm on prophecy and what has been
prophesied okay good question um
you know the bible tells us and there's
a principle that we find well several
that we find first of all to the law
under the testimony if they speak not
according to this there is no light in
them so anybody that has a theory or an
idea it needs to be in harmony with the
scripture but then when it comes to
prophecy there's a lot of different
interpretations of prophecy and the
verse that comes to mind is second peter
chapter 1 verse 20
where peter says knowing this first that
no prophecy of the scripture is for any
private interpretation
now what that means is it's not for us
to take a verse of scripture to pick a
passage in revelation or in daniel
and say well this means this or this
symbol is identifying this power
we can't do that what we have to do is
allow the bible to interpret itself
and so when it comes to the different
symbols and the different powers
that are working in the last days to
bring about end time events we need to
make sure that we allow the bible to
interpret itself and the bible gives us
a number of clues
as to who the big players are so to
speak
in end time events you go to revelation
chapter 13 you have one beast that comes
up from the sea you have another beast
that comes up from the earth you
parallel that with what we read in
revelation chapter 17
and some other passages in daniel daniel
makes it very clear that the key play is
at the end of time is a religious system
we know that as the papacy we know the
united states plays a very significant
role that is the second beast of
revelation chapter 13. so when it comes
to understanding these end time events
we always have to filter it through
you know what the bible says and
allowing the bible to interpret itself
that's one principle the second
principle we need to ask is well what's
the point of this theory or this idea
does it lead to repentance or is it just
a sensational idea
why is somebody promoting it
does it lead to holiness does it lead to
a clear understanding of bible truth
uh what about the fruits of the life of
the person that is promoting it we also
need to bear in mind that if somebody
has genuine truth usually it's re it's
revealed through multiple
individuals
it's not just one person the bible
speaks about in the mouth of two or
three witnesses
every truth is to be established it's
not just one bible verses multiple bible
verses
i would be leery of somebody who comes
up with something totally different from
everybody else
and he claims to have some special
revelation from god and he believes this
is the message that the world needs to
hear right now and you don't see that in
scripture i would be very leery of that
does that help anthony
yes that's very helpful thank you and i
i just take it as the word of god is uh
the bible gotta be tested with the word
of god
absolutely yes thank you very much all
right thanks for your call anthony we've
got dennis listening in uh south
carolina dennis welcome to the program
hey pastor ross how are you doing well
thank you
all right so um
my question is pertaining to
um i guess
because we are living in the last days
um and there is an awakening
uh spiritual awakening especially for
the jewish people
um there is this
organization if i made called one for
israel and
it seems like there's a lot of israeli
jews that are starting to accept jesus
christ as the messiah
um
is that something that is prophesied in
the bible as maybe that being part of
the remnant church
and um is there anything that maybe
amazing facts is doing or will do in the
future maybe to help promote and get
this gospel
especially the new testament out to you
know
god's people
yeah good question um i think that yes
the jewish people um individuals
definitely um
will come to a clear and full
understanding
and you know some of the leading
christian voices i know pastor doug who
is the leader here at amazing facts he's
half jewish and i know of another i know
of several other jewish
christians who are committed to the lord
and involved in ministry and evangelism
and outreach
and i think it's going to continue as
time goes on we're going to see more and
more individual jews
see the truth of christ being the
messiah they'll accept him they'll
accept the truths of the sabbath along
with all of the other
truths that we find in the bible
but will israel as a nation
accept christ as the messiah i don't
think that's going to happen
israel today is a very secular country
you might have some groups within israel
who are still
very religious but by far the majority
of those in israel
are secular they don't read the bible
they don't study
and
you know i think their probationary time
as an entire nation
has come to an end when they rejected
jesus there was really nothing more that
god could do to try and reach them as a
nation
but what god is doing is he's reaching
individuals and he's calling them to a
clearer understanding of truth and i
think there's going to be revival
amongst the jewish people who are
sincerely seeking truth just like
there's going to be revival amongst
christians
who are going to look for a deeper
understanding of bible truth so god is
going to gather together in the last
days
those who are sincere in following him
who are committed to keeping his
commandments those who have the faith of
jesus the testimony of jesus the bible
says if you are christ then you are
abraham's seed heirs according to the
promise
so if we believe in jesus and receive
him
there is a wonderful promise that we get
to receive all the promises that god
made to abraham
so yeah i think there is going to be a
revival
in the last days but don't look for the
whole nation of israel
to suddenly accept jesus as the messiah
well thanks for your call we've got
jonathan listening in canada jonathan
welcome to the program
jonathan in canada you're on the air
yes hi jonathan
oh how are you customers doing well
thank you
um i have a question i'm
i'm a young teenager
and i've been recently struggling with
doubts on my face
and i want to know how can i you know
how can i strengthen my faith
okay good question what do we do with
doubts now if you're going to be honest
i think every person every christian has
doubts that come from time to time
first of all we want to make sure that
we're arming our minds filling our minds
with truth
and we find truth in the word of god so
it begins by spending time
reading the bible you know i do that
every day i'll
set time aside and i'll read the bible i
think we just need to read the word of
god i study the word of god i like to
spend time
amongst people who are talking about the
word of god that strengthens our faith
but even saying all of that there are
still doubts that come into a person's
mind
uh what we can do is we can choose
whether or not to dwell upon that doubt
somebody once said you can't stop the
bird flying over your head
but you can stop the bird making a nest
in your hair
so if you have a doubt coming to your
mind or an idea coming to your mind you
can choose whether or not to dwell upon
that realize that the devil is always
trying to create doubts with reference
to the word of god god's plan god's love
and he's going to do that every time he
can but we can choose whether or not we
want to dwell on those doubts replace
the doubt with a promise of the word of
god how did jesus overcome temptation he
quoted scripture he said man shall not
live by bread alone but by every word
that proceeds out of the mouth of god
and so as we fill our minds with truth
these become our defenses
against doubt
does that help uh jonathan
jonathan you're there another question
yeah go ahead
um so
what if it's like
you're in the face you know like
how do you gain passion for the faith
again because i was once like
on fire for god and i really loved you
know studying his work but like recently
with doubts and
suspicions you know
it just makes me
doesn't seem kind of lost so how do you
regain it how do you how do you regain
that first love as the bible says um
well it begins by spending time in god's
word and spending time in prayer and it
requires an effort we've got to put some
effort in but if we would just
faithfully do our part
spend time in the word spend time in
prayer
fill our minds with spiritual truth
then god the holy spirit is able to work
in us
both to willing to do according to his
good pleasure so my challenge to anyone
who is wondering about you know i don't
feel real connected or real
committed i would say well make a
commitment to spend a half an hour a day
reading the word
and then spend at least 15 minutes in
prayer twice a day that's the sort of
prescription you might say and when you
pray let me just share one quick thought
here about prayer sometimes people
struggle what do you do when you pray i
think of the word pray p-r-a-y and i
think of each of those letters as
representing something so when you pray
you begin with praise so the p stands
for praise think of something specific
that you can praise god for
something that he did for you that day
and then you go on to the the r and the
r stands for repentance and then you've
got to ask yourself lord what is it that
i need to repent of whether it's my
attitude something i said something i
did the way i treated somebody else so
we've got to spend some time repenting
and that's the r and then the a's is the
asking that's where we bring all our
petitions before the lord not only do we
ask god for physical blessings and for
our needs but i think more importantly
god wants us to ask for spiritual
blessings
asking for guidance of spirit
and then the why
is for healed or surrender
so when you pray you want to spend some
time don't just
ramble through something but spend time
thinking specifically about something
you can praise god for something that
you need to ask repentance of or repent
of
something you need to ask him and then
what is it in your life that you want to
surrender or heal to him
and as you do this i guarantee you as
you do this faithfully day after day
that'll enable the spirit of god to do a
work in you and you will be amazed
you'll say this is not me doing this
this is god working in me and through me
after all god wants to save us god is
not willing that any should perish
but he wants all to come to repentance
so jonathan that's that's where it
starts and i think that's true not only
to you jonathan but anyone that's out
there if you want to have a revival in
your life
start with prayer start with bible study
you might even want to enroll in one of
the amazing facts study guide courses
maybe you've never gone through a whole
bible study series amazing facts offers
these up for free we have a
correspondence course we will actually
send you the lesson in the mail you can
fill it out you'll send it back to us
we'll grade it and you can go through
all of our 27
study guides we have different courses
on different subjects that will
strengthen your knowledge of bible truth
and strengthen your understanding in
what the bible says
so just the fact that you know you're
listening to bible answers live means
that you have an interest in spiritual
things it means the holy spirit is
working upon your heart so you want to
try and encourage that and give
opportunity for the spirit to work
through you through the word and through
prayer and you will grow spiritually
well friends we don't have time to take
another call are we coming up on our
break halfway through the program the
program is by no means over we're just
going to take a quick break and then
we'll take more bible questions the
phone line if you have a bible question
is 800-463-7297
that is with your bible question
also our free offer number is
800-835-6747
and we'll be giving out different free
offers connected with the various bible
questions so don't go too far we'll be
back in just a few moments for more
bible questions
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
would you like to live closer to christ
and share him better then don't miss the
upcoming amazing facts youth conference
the theme is trials to triumph the power
of the story expect outstanding speakers
thrilling testimonies wonderful music
and plan to make some new friends among
the hundreds of other spiritual young
people best of all the whole weekend is
absolutely free
join us live at the granite bay hilltop
church or go to afyouth.com
[Music]
every year 40 000 souls in north america
end their own lives
suicide is a terrible tragedy and while
it's difficult to talk about we need to
face it together as christians
that's why in my new book choosing life
i share the biblical perspective about
suicide answering some difficult
questions about faith and salvation
along the way and offering practical
tips that should help and encourage
others jesus wants us to choose an
abundant life in him are you looking for
a simple way to share your faith
if you've ever found yourself
tongue-tied when trying to explain what
the bible teaches about the sabbath the
second coming or the afterlife
you'll love the new amazing facts tracks
these colorful tracks feature easy to
read type and are large enough to grab
everyone's attention but small enough to
fit in your pocket to carry with you
wherever you go
eleven key bible teachings are available
now purchase a sample bundle to see what
fits your needs then buy them in bulk
and save
equip yourself and your church to reach
your community with the eye-catching
amazing facts tracks
amazing facts tracks easy to read easy
to share
to order your sample bundle call
800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
and get ready to share your faith like
never before
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends welcome back to bible
answers live my name is jean ross pastor
doug batch lays out this evening but he
will god willing be with us again next
uh next week for another live bible
answers live program
but if you have a bible related question
you heard the phone line one more time
it's
800-463-7297 with your bible question we
have a number of folks waiting online so
we're going to get right to it next
quarter that we have is share listening
from hawaii share welcome to the program
from pastor ross hello
hi
um my question is um
um
is there anything um where i can find
the bible in the stereo processor
okay question about uh uh are they
inhabited worlds is that what you're
asking about yeah okay
yeah you know the bible is not clearly
stating that um at least not it gives us
a description of these worlds but it
does use
the word worlds in the plural form and
we find that in hebrews chapter 1 verse
it says through him through christ all
things were created and it also talks
about the worlds so that's hebrews
chapter 1 verse 1 and then also if you
go to the book of of job you will read
about a gathering of the sons of god and
the devil came and god said where did
you come from and he said well i came
from the earth so the devil came as a
representative from the earth claiming
the earth as his but there were these
other
created beings known as sons of god or
referred to as sons of god a number of
bible scholars believed that they could
symbolize
these other worlds that are the
representatives of these unfallen worlds
now we know earth is the only one that
that fell into satan's trap
that's why jesus came and died on the
earth here
so those are some of the verses that we
have that speak about worlds we of
course we know angels the bible speaks
about angels both good angels and bad
angels but those are some of the verses
that talk about other worlds
we got iran listening from new york iran
welcome to the program
good evening pastor ross thank you for
taking my call sure
in
matthew chapter 23 verse 9
jesus said do not call anyone on earth
your father for one is your father
who
he who is in heaven
and in first corinthians chapter 4
verses 14
through 17 says
i do not write these things to shame you
but as my beloved children i warn you
for though you might have ten thousand
instructors in christ yet you do not
have many fathers
for in christ jesus i have begotten you
through the gospel
therefore i heard you
imitate me
for this reason i have sent timothy to
you who is my beloved and faithful son
in the lord who will remind you of
my ways in christ as i teach anywhere in
every church
can you comment to come out yeah i'd be
happy to
ask this yes the bible does tell us that
we ought to call no man
father and when he says call no man
father he's not talking about our
earthly father or our real father
there's nothing wrong in calling your
father father
but it's talking about a religious
leader as referring to that religious
leader or calling that religious leader
by the name
father
of course we know there's a whole
movement today there's a whole church
out there who
call their religious leaders fathers and
the bible says no don't do that you have
one father and that is your father in
heaven so what paul is talking about
he's not asking anyone to call him
father he's just using a family
relationship to try and illustrate that
he was the one that had planted the
church
the church in corinth and that's why
when he says to the believers there he
says you have many teachers in christ
meaning they probably had a number of
teachers and pastors and yet you only
have one who have begot who has begotten
you and he's speaking about himself he
was the one that planted the church so
he's speaking to them as the one who had
invested so much in them coming to a
knowledge or the understanding of the
truth
but paul was not asking the believers to
refer to him as father because that of
course would be contradicting what jesus
said
but in the in the way that paul planted
the church he was their father meaning
he was the one that
invested and planted the church and he
sent
a very beloved follower of his
and refers to him as his son
and he was the one that was to instruct
them and guide them in more truth
so paul's not asking the believers to
refer to him as father
does that help iran okay
yes yeah he's just making making the
point that he was the one that planted
the church
in that sense all right well thanks for
your call we've got steve listening in
canada montreal steve welcome to the
program
yes good evening pastor john appreciate
um
to help me out to help me and get closer
to that it's the fourth time i can call
i just would like to say um
i bought in south africa because i play
music violin
and pursuit of i've been in all five
continents playing on cruise ship and i
know you are from south africa because i
was in cape town
the
i saw the people mountains just
beautiful yes okay very good
i know that well i've climbed table
mountain
you're doing the question and answers
may i ask you the first time you're
doing alone uh no we've done in the past
sometimes when i'm gone or past the
doug's gone then we'll just kind of
trade off or we'll try to get somebody
else to fill in
but um yeah and what's your question
tonight steve yeah great thank you thank
you very much for for you for pastor uh
doug bashir for everybody carlos munoz
daniel hodges i i appreciate everything
the ef coe everything i did it with the
tony scalpino with everything so i tried
no no no no no no no here's my question
um thank you much for your time and
listening
i saw this uh quote today on facebook
and i thought in the past two i'm going
to read it i wonder if it's correct or
if it's false it's about the shabbat
this is what it says
the very name sabat is god's mark or
sign of authority the hebrew word is
shabbat
and it says
s-h-a-a means eternal bond a-b is a
root word for
a-b-b-a
and means father b-a-p-h or
b-a-e-p-h-k means has of or sign of
sign of the eternal father is it
something really this so
different meanings in the world of of
the oral hebrew word of shabbat or this
is something that is not really
important it's just gibberish what do
you think no i definitely think there's
something to that you know these um you
look at the different names in the bible
that god gave
a lot of them have deeper meaning and
understanding when you look at the
sabbath um it's a reference to the fact
that god is our creator he is our father
he's the one that made us
and the word abba that we find the word
abba meaning father it's interesting to
see that in the word sabbath and then
also if you go to the fourth commandment
there's many different passages in
scripture you can see how the sabbath
becomes a sign
that god is the one who made us and in
keeping the sabbath we're acknowledging
him as our creator and as our god so yes
i think there is definitely something to
that and there's probably a lot of
wonderful truths that you can you can
discover by studying into some of the
original meaning of the root words
that you get these different words in
the bible from great point steve thank
you for your question
we've got samuel listening in wisconsin
samuel welcome to the program
mayor not the jesus pastor hello
i'm calling to refer to the epistle of
james chapter one verse five okay
as i grow on my face searching for the
lord
i notice that i come under more attack
by the enemy
and i'm overcoming that
as i'm being taken at different levels
but i was wondering if you could help me
with that on number five sure asking for
wisdom for discernment yes and
perception let me read the verse for
those who might be driving in their car
uh james chapter one verse five if
anyone lacks wisdom let him ask of god
who gives to all liberally and without
reproach and it will be given to him
so here god wants us to have another
knowledge or an understanding of the
truth the bible says you shall know the
truth and the truth shall make you free
jesus said i am the way the truth and
the life and so when we come to god with
sincerity and we say lord please
lead me into a clear understanding of
bible truth and then we allow the word
of god to teach us to speak and
we pray that god will guide us god will
lead us if we have an open heart
of course we always want to test
everything by the word of god but if we
are sincere god will lead us into a
fuller and clearer understanding of
bible truth you know i do bible studies
with individuals and we discover truths
in scripture that they've never seen
before and when they see it they say
this makes sense i've been praying
asking god i've always wanted to
understand what happens when a person
dies what does the bible really say
about that subject
and god led them and they've come to a
clear understanding not only on that
subject but many different subjects in
the bible so if we have a sincere heart
and we are seeking to know the truth
then we can trust that god will lead us
into a clear understanding of truth take
advantage of the the resources that's
available too
uh and again i want to encourage folks
if you're wanting to understand bible
truth take a look at the amazing facts
study guides it's just jam-packed with
bible verses and i'll make a lot of
important bible truths clear
thank you for your call samuel we've got
zoe listening in canada zoey welcome to
the program
hi how are you doing well thank you
that's great i was just wondering if you
could explain the trinity to me whether
god jesus and the holy spirit are all
one or whether they're separate okay
great question so in the bible you find
a a word one for example you have in the
old testament hero israel the lord thy
god is one
and it's interesting to note that the
word one has a plural application or a
plural meaning
for example jesus said for this call
shall a man leave his father and his
mother and the two shall be joined
together
and they shall become one
now when it uses the word one in that
sense it's not talking about one
numerically but one in purpose they are
united so when the bible says that the
lord thy god is one
god the father god the son god the holy
spirit they are united in their work of
saving mankind they all share the
characteristics of deity meaning they
have no beginning they have no end they
are all powerful
they a complete and perfect
demonstration of love
and the father son and holy spirit are
all working for man's salvation so they
are united in that sense they are one
but there are three separate beings when
jesus was on the earth he prayed to the
father in heaven and the holy spirit
came upon jesus in the form of a dove
so three separate beings but they are
united they are one in their purpose and
their mission to save mankind
does does that help a little
it does thank you so much okay thank you
for your call
we've got uh caleb listening in new york
caleb welcome to the program
how you doing pastor ross thank you for
doing well thank you
all right um i have a question
my question is more like a suggestion
actually i'm trying i wanna
my goal is to be able to preach
more
the word of god but every time it seems
like i try
it seems like i'm always end up in like
some like
debate which i don't like i feel like
it's not spirit-led
it's more like ego led for me so
i don't feel good about it i just need
to know
how can i um
do that better and
like
to be able to preach the word um
to people yeah and i find it hard to to
also i also find it hard to preach
people
who are
from religions who don't believe
like we have to keep the ten
commandments and i feel
like it contradicts the bible and the
reason why jesus died
um
and when you and they
would um like quote um scriptures from
the bible
and they just they'll quote scriptures
in the bible
and
that don't align with what i'm
you know with the bible and they confuse
other people which i don't agree with
and my second question is is about
revelations
212.
um is it
talking about really the station west
like because someone was telling me oh
it's like where st satan lives it's like
it's like thrown i i don't understand
all right let me i don't believe that's
what it meant yeah let me read the verse
for those who might be listening
uh revelation chapter 2 verse 12 which
says to the angel the church of pogo
must write these things say to you as
the sharp two-edged sword i know your
works where you dwell where satan's
throne is and you hold fast my name and
you did not deny my faith even in the
days when antipas my faithful martyr who
was killed among you where satan dwells
so your question is
what is it there where it talks about
satan's throne
is that the question yeah okay someone
was saying that's like that that is
wrong
yeah no what it's referring to there is
satan stronghold so they were believers
in the city the ancient city of pergamos
who were living in a very pagan society
and there was a lot of pagan rituals
that were taking place
the local people in the city worshipping
a number of pagan deities
and despite the fact that there was so
much paganism
there were these faithful followers of
christ who were holding to the truth and
there were even some who were martyred
for their faith
so he's referring to the city where they
were living where there was a lot of
paganism because of the paganism and the
false doctrine and the false worship
it's referred to as satan's seat meaning
the folks the people in that city they
were under the power the demonic power
of satan in following all of these pagan
rituals and practices it's got a broader
prophetic application
um when you look at the different
churches in revelation but i think
historically for the actual church of
pergamos that's the reference there the
second or the first question that you
mentioned i should say something about
that before we run out of time
you know we are called to give a witness
or a testimony of our faith
but you are right when you get into an
argument uh you might even win the
argument but really lose the battle the
purpose for us in sharing bible truth is
to allow uh the spirit of god to work
upon the hearts of the people
and um we need to pray for guidance
there are times for us to keep quiet
there are times for us to speak
and in our discourse we're always
looking to try and awaken
a deeper and a fuller desire to know the
truth and i think that's where your
personal testimony is so powerful people
can't argue with your personal testimony
it's your experience so if you can share
how that some particular bible truth has
changed your life
and brought peace and understanding they
can't argue with that
if anything they might wonder well i
want that kind of peace too and maybe
they'll be open whereas if you just hit
them with a whole bunch of proof texts
they might they might resist that
so the power of a personal testimony is
still a wonderful way of of opening the
heart so a person is wanting to hear
more bible truth
all right well thanks for your quote
thank you so much hopefully that helped
yeah thank you so much next quarter that
we have is um let's see we have got
brenda listening in ohio brenda welcome
to the program
brand are you there
yeah see him hi brenda and your question
um my question is um
i wonder what the bible says about me
uh taking some college classes
on the sabbath that i work full-time and
i have a chance to increase my education
but for two months straight it would be
on the sabbath and then every other
weekend
for 16 months
well that's a good question you know we
did have a caller that asked a little
bit about that and there are folks that
come to me all the time as a past and
they ask you know here's the situation
in college the first thing i try to do
is you know you want to try and
communicate with your with your lecturer
or with the school and find out if there
is some credit or some additional work
to be done on a different day
so you can keep the sabbath after all
you really want god's blessing to be on
your schoolwork on your study
and god can't bless something if we
knowingly are doing something that he's
asked us not to do
so you know that's where we need to pray
about and say lord please give me the
courage to step out in faith and do what
i know you're asking me to do and trust
that you will work things out now that
might mean that we have to maybe go to a
different school that might mean we have
to talk to our teachers
it might mean some changes in our
schedule
but you know you will have a peace and a
joy
knowing that you're doing what god is
asking you to do and you can trust in
him so
yes there are times where our faith will
be tested and tried and i think here's
an opportunity for a person who might be
facing that situation
it might even be a work situation
they're requiring the work that's
requiring them to work on the sabbath
well if if they make a stand for what
they know to be true from the bible i
think god will be able to bless them and
open up a door and lead them in a
different direction so
brenda i just want to encourage you that
do what you know to be right the holy
spirit is speaking to your heart stand
true to the word and then pray that god
will open up a door and lead you where
he needs you to go
next quarter that we have let's see is
jacob listening from louisiana i'm not
sure if i pronounce your name correctly
jacob yes
yes
hi um
thank you so much for your ministry it's
blessed me so much but my question is
why is the casting out of demons not
done by christians today as done in
biblical times like specifically
in jesus's ministry like everywhere him
and the disciples went they were always
casting out demons and acknowledging
that people weren't even possessed and i
just don't see that a lot you know what
i'm saying right right well you know
it's also that the devil is very subtle
in the way that he does things uh in
more sort of western cultures you might
say people are somewhat skeptical and so
he doesn't manifest himself in that way
as he would in some other places
i'm from south africa i grew up there
and we spent time in the mission field
and some in these some of these remote
areas where
paganism is very strong and people are
actually worshiping
demons unknowingly i have encountered
demon-possessed people and it is a scary
thing it's not something you'll look for
it's very real
and
you pray for them uh some demons require
a prayer and fasting but you gather the
elders of the church and you pray
sincerely for that person and i've seen
multiple times where an evil spirit has
come out of someone in that type of
situation so it's very real people can
be demon-possessed but i think in a
western culture people are a little more
skeptical of that they might put it down
to some sort of
you know mental disorder or who knows
what they'll come up with so the devil
works in different ways
but the end game is the same he still
has just as much control over people in
western culture
through
all the deceptions and the entertainment
and the love of money
as he does over people who you might
think of or we might think of as being
demon possessed in some far-flung
country so he's got his different needs
and he changes it based upon what's
going to suit his agenda the best
does does that help
it does i just i guess i want like you
touched on a little bit like mental
health and like drug addiction and like
there's so much suicide going on and
stuff like that like i wonder if a lot
of that is
demon possession and then like what
should we be doing as christians well
you know i think there's both i mean
it's definitely practical and i think we
all understand that
there can be some very real mental
diseases or chemical reactions that take
place or as a result of drugs or
something along those lines that people
are not thinking clearly they're not
themselves
but then there are
areas where somebody might open up a
door uh whether it's the music they're
listening to the movies they're watching
and you know when you think about it in
western societies it is just filled with
um the occult movies music
books and so the devil's definitely
alive and well
and
leading people astray
so the bible speaks about a battle not
between flesh and blood but against
principalities and powers and so yes the
devil is very much alive and he's
he's influencing uh people all the time
right right
well thank you so much i appreciate your
time all right thanks for your call next
caller that we have is uh
kantika listening from massachusetts not
sure if i pronounce your name correctly
kantika
yeah yeah you um close enough
okay yeah
welcome and your question tonight
my question is regarding the mixed
multitude in the day of moses the bible
talked about how the strangers they
weren't welcome into the camp until the
third generation
and i was wondering about you know what
this means because obviously like we
have examples in the bibles like people
who weren't israelites that were like
welcome to the camp like rahab for an
example and stuff yes so what does the
bible mean when it says that for one
thing
and is there like a modern application
because we're spiritual israel yeah what
did that mean
so when we talk about the mixed
multitude back in the time of moses and
the israelites they journeyed with the
israelites they were in the camp but
they weren't able to actually
participate
in the formal worship connected with the
sanctuary
and the reason for that was the mixed
multitude very often would be the reason
why israel would
rebel against god they would be
influenced by the mixed multitude many
of the people that came with them out of
egypt left because they saw the signs
they were afraid but they weren't truly
converted and so to make sure that
there's genuine conversion that's why
god said it's going to be four
generations you want to make sure that
the person is fully committed to the god
of israel
and that they're not going to lead
israel astray but having said that god
designed israel to be a light to all of
the nations around them they would be
telling people the truth
and the
the temple or the sanctuary was referred
to as a place of prayer for all nations
so as far as people coming to find truth
or to seek god yeah absolutely they were
welcome to do that now in a modern
application i think in the church we
want to welcome anyone who is sincere
wanting to know truth wanting to
understand the bible but when it comes
to actually becoming a member of the
church i think we want to make sure that
that person first of all is fully
converted that they have an
understanding of the fundamental
teachings of the bible
and that they make a public
confession
to those truths and often that is
accompanied by
baptism by immersion
so
yes anyone's welcome to come to church
if they sincerely wanting to learn truth
but in order to become a member of the
church they need to make sure they know
we know what it is that they are
committing to and they need to make that
public confession of their faith through
baptism they want to follow jesus so i
think there's also an application even
here we can see that even in our time
today
uh does does that help does that make
sense
yeah
so god was not exclusive wanting to
not allow certain people but he wanted
to make sure that those who connected
themselves to israel were sincere and
fully committed that was the purpose of
that
okay thank you all right you're welcome
thanks for your call
we got time maybe for one more caller
let's see we've got david listening in
jamaica david welcome to the program we
have about a minute
yes good night buster hi there
yes i was basically baffled on a quest
on a by the verse i was reading the
other day
and it was taken from revelation
chapter one verse seven yes and you know
what i'm we're gonna run out of time
david are you wondering about every eye
seeing jesus
when he comes okay yes the verse doesn't
say that when jesus comes everyone will
see him at exactly the same time but it
says everyone will see him so it's quite
possible that as jesus comes in the
clouds of heaven the earth is still
rotating on its axis
and within a 24-hour period of time
every eye will see jesus
when he comes so the second coming of
christ you know it'll take time people
will be able to see jesus coming the
earth will will turn on its axis
but
you know the second coming the angels
and the cloud could swoop around the
earth very quickly as well so when it
says every eye shall see and the bible
doesn't give us the specifics on that
but we can trust what the word says when
jesus comes everyone will see him
friends um we're gonna say goodbye to
those listening on satellite radio but
don't go too far you got more questions
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
hello friends welcome back we've got
about two and a half minutes before we
actually finish out the program with
those who are watching on af tv or
watching on social media or listening on
land-based radio stations so thank you
for staying with us for this final
two minutes we'd like to take some time
to answer the many bible questions that
people emailed to us here and so i've
got a list of some questions and we're
going to try to get through as many of
these questions as we can in the next
few minutes
so the first question we have is can we
live a sinless life in jesus can we live
a sinless life well the bible says if
the son sets you free you shall be free
indeed
in other words there is no excuse for
sin we can't say well you know i'm a
human being and so i'm just going to go
ahead and sin and god will understand i
think the real point here is that if we
trust that god is able to do all things
and we surrender ourselves to him
we want to ask and believe that he can
give us the victory and that's the good
news of the gospel jesus can set you
free
there is no point in our experience
where we feel as though we've overcome
all things and we're perfect but we're
always to be striving towards complete
and full surrender to christ a perfect
person is a person fully surrendered to
jesus in every area of their life
that's the thing that we are are seeking
and trusting that god can do
another question that we have
are the ten commandments
only for the old testament or only in
old testament times well i think if you
read the new testament you discover that
the principles are the ten commandments
and the ten commandments themselves are
also outlined in the gospels in the new
testament all the commandments a matter
of fact you go to the sermon on the
mount that jesus preached and he said
well you've heard it said of old you
should not kill
but i say unto you if you're angry with
your brother without a cause you are
guilty of
murdering your heart so jesus took the
principles of the ten commandments the
new testament and expanded them he gave
them a much broader and deeper practical
application
another question we have is who is
leviathan and i'm assuming this question
is related to that verse in job talks
about this animal that lives in the sea
describes almost like a dragon like
creature living in the sea leviathan now
of course leviathan or a dragon is often
a symbol that is used of the devil
and the devil is the one who controls
multitudes and nations and kindreds and
tongues and in the bible prophecy the
sea represents multitudes and nations
it is possible that before the flood
there were some kind of a reptile that
lived in the sea that might resemble the
description that we find in the book of
job but in a spiritual application the
dragon or leviathan would be a symbol of
the devil as we see that in different
bible types and symbols again we want to
welcome those for joining us tonight for
our bible answer live program look
forward to talking again next week
you